[Applause]
hmm
show that shit shut up so in honor of
this we've got the Kaiser a fight Avery
brewery wise this is we're not
yeah we're not advertising right no
because I thought it was frickin
hilarious because it's a World War one
moving I'm uncool but Kaiser we got a
good DC yeah drink to the Germans
coverage that it's all oh hello my lord
um ah it's always around food gets good
movie it's a good movie oh yeah uh just
good okay it's not all going to be that
but I just got back from a vacation
literally the first thing I want to do
why this is days late yeah yeah well by
internet standards we'll go up on like
Monday I think but for the internet
that's like what happen here man
everyone's already talked about it but
ya know I uh
everyone's going fucking nuts for this
movie like you're just like one woman
finally good DC movie is great and just
everyone's loving the hell out of it and
I'm just saying I psycho by might fix it
in like oh good can this really big
thank you and I said I don't care what
you're doing in San Francisco drop the
fucking rice-a-roni and go see the movie
and uh hell it's pretty good
um can't say flawless you know but I
mean no not a few movies are flawless
and you can even argue no movie is
really flawless but yeah I know movie to
me is flawless and on top of that it's
like even even things like The Dark
Knight I can nitpick and it burns famine
and the donners Superman and but I mean
like it's closer to those level of me
really the best deed then just a bit
what it he'll get that DC movie at CSIS
Dark Knight yeah yeah easily uh and you
know what's funny is that everyone has
come out about this movie everyone's
loving it and I think the only movie
where people would just really split
love or hate felt like Man of Steel uh
yeah either love it or you hate
there's a very few okay and then I'm
going at and well and then with the
other DC movies there's always like a
either hated or even if you like it
yeah good just you know do you like man
maybe super music yeah it's good if you
like Suicide Squad yeah you know there's
this one there's not really much yeah
it's like it's really really solid and
the first thing is it uses a lot of very
familiar cliches you know we've seen
these cliches a lot of times yeah fish
out of water you know kind of thing you
know it is you have to be worth it we've
seen that lots of times idea it's like
if you cross Captain America with Thor
with Lord of the Rings 300 and Raiders
of the Lost Ark I'll even go so far as
to say the effects are not good in this
movie then all just think they're really
shallow they are not gonna go ahead and
you know what kills me is no they're not
good effect at all and I love this bag
yeah I wonder why because it style of
effect kind of works it looks like a
comic book and so the fake eNOS of it to
me kind of worked I have a problem um
but better give honestly I for the most
part there are a couple things in Batman
vs Superman I had problems with the
effects but honestly didn't have any
problem with the effects in those movies
I honestly think the effects are better
than those movies in this movie hands
down oh yeah uh definitely and Man of
Steel and stuff like that does not
matter
no no because one this is always the
thing with people are like oh you're
nitpicking the affectionate taking all
this stuff you know in a bad movie it's
much easier to do because you're not
distracted by how good the rest of it in
how good the story only to make the
effects there but said read or watch
this movie a hundred times versus Batman
vs Superman yeah uh and you know I
didn't know a ton about one or one that
and do a little bit I knew you know on
an island I thought you were the goddess
then here in she's an Amazon I'm here
and she's a princess I'm here into the
warrior then the end guys gotta see nori
gulf it's from clay
ya know that was another thing jump ask
me that
that's one thing I kind of miss I
whispered because this will be going all
out say hey we're going to show you the
damn ion when we're not going to try it
grow it up or anything but we're gonna
show you this island really makes me
feel like it's a damn I wonder what you
wanted to you're sculpted
what a party yeah a part of me
completely agree with you and that I
have this image to like it's something
out of ghost where it's like you got the
pottery wheels like a blanket you're
gonna kill me because I forget this
guy's name but this is life yeah he did
the opening credits for spider-man - he
said brilliant artist I forget his name
I'm so sorry but he did online I'm
blanking too but one of my being
introductions to wonder what I love the
opening credits of spider-man - he's a
phenomenal artists and one of my big
introductions - Wonder Woman turns like
what the backstory was is that he did
wanna be huge he kind of like these big
picture books they're comics but they're
huge and they're these incredible almost
realistic paintings and drawings and it
was just these this is where I said this
could be a movie because he just shat
everything was kinda like a permit
sunset and the Sun was always shining in
and just all the Amazons were there okay
okay and one of them was the mother
creating Diana out of clay it was just
this beautiful image and maybe in a
future movie I can see that you know a
really cool in it I'll tell you what I
like though is that this movie felt like
that because as much as we're just like
yeah the special effects aren't good the
digital artistic quality of them the way
that you could tell us obviously digital
just kind of helped this movie but
because it felt like a very fancy
graphic novel and I like a guy named yet
the whole thing and the the way the
mascara is just like so gorgeous I mean
it's shot in Greece I'm assuming which
is gorgeous they got like the bluest
water there in the bluest skies and but
even he did more they all street singing
all the songs I'm sorry that would have
made this a perfect film I would you
know if that happened I would have shot
my I would have liked I would have
pulled out a glider one
my brought out over I went up into Mamma
Mia soon so excited we can do see Mamma
Mia turn the ends upside down wonder won
gather we give it up sorry um
fucking you I'm just giddy because I got
a good DC movie I'm sorry uh no but okay
here's the thing everyone's always like
oh you just want hate on DC though we
love these heroes and bitter really felt
like I had those are the sad fanboys who
are just so desperate they're like every
conspiracy put on their little tin foil
it yes it is no thank you
I wish God Jesus I wish I'd been with it
wouldn't be living here I can tell you
that how about Damien was given much
nicer review door hell yeah but uh ya
know in heroes don't listen don't listen
to them there's always going to be an
insane cause I got like it to I mean
it's a DC movie I mean that's a nice
thing you know knowing the way they work
though busy yeah so you are holding out
all the conspiracies um no it's I'll pay
the real big thing I like about this
movie and this what separates this go on
know what separates the prior superhero
movies coming out you know because for a
year is kind of a Golden Age of comics
when there was like Superman Batman and
Wonder Woman and stuff you know and they
were you know during wartime and all
diddled um you know it was the Golden
Age and there were the role models we
looked up to him and stuff but after a
while they said let's make it more
personal and a long team kind of like
the 70s into the 80s and we guess with
the Frank Miller bad man and then we got
movies that were reflecting the dark
brooding superhero and they made it more
personal yeah and Spiderman was kind of
about that and all they had up okay
that's an over simplification no no but
I'm saying in terms of movies no because
there's tons of calm because double
triple superhero movies when they came
back you know sort of with Dark Knight
and x-men stuff they made it very much
about the individual which needed to
happen and it's not bad at all is most
of them are very well done but we kind
of catch I feel what you're missing
you're missing a key point with that
though which is DC decided to kind of do
that as well and that's Marvel's
wheelhouse no no no no hold on hold on
but but
so I'm getting to eat whether it's done
well or not done well this is kind of
what they were doing and it made sense
it was a way to get people more involved
cuz hey I feel like I can be this person
I feel like it'd be the superhero when I
see Batman in any movie I see Batman
well I see spider-man a movie in it is
done well you know I see spider-man you
know same thing with Superman it's done
well when I saw Wonder Woman in this
when I saw her get out onto the field
you know on two out of the trenches and
stuff like that I saw hero I know it
felt really cliche but I'm lying like
she is walking around I got Greek hero I
was like there's fuckin Hercules it is
definitely about the hero's journey but
it is about the people she wants to save
the people this is what Superman in the
diner films used to be and then when and
this is even now argue what Superman
Returns tried to do didn't succeed but
try to do and then yeah they want to
make it about the individual again in
Manistee land vanity Superman but like
for example in those movies when a whole
bunch of people thought well firstly
maybe argument Superman doesn't really
say those people he fights not from
above whatever Bennett V Superman when
that giant explosion happens you know
the courthouse everyone just said what's
the rent reaction hmm yeah that sucks
this whole movie like that scowl to just
to kind of like I half of this movie is
just her reaction seeing these people
suffer what about being a woman and she
doesn't understand you know to how that
actually did that right because that
garbage scene it is trash that trash
scene in Man of Steel we're fucking
psycho Paul cans is like what should i
do dad does I'm during the my booth
lighten and I'm like terrible and in
this one and going through the trenches
and that sounds so organic and so right
where she like but these people in from
anyone in rich feel anything like oh you
need hand save everybody like it gave an
impetus like you felt the drive the
whole scene work and it's not wrong he's
not wrong guard and she's not wrong
either these are two different outlooks
and they constantly are
title butting heads but it's not like a
dumb rom-com where it's like oh they
hate each other they're gonna have
together like you oh no I'm gonna make
you know and that is a huge thing about
this movie like this to me dispels the
myth and I thought whether it's a DC fan
or Marvel fan saying it it was it was a
stupid myth and I hope this buries it
for good which is well yeah I'm the only
female yeah me too get it it's exactly
like a Marvel movie like this a lot of
that no this is zero to do with Marvin
you can see there me like one kind of
reminds me of Captain America this movie
has a sense of humor not once that I
think oh this is like a Marvin we
because you said exactly this would have
been a shitty-ass rom-com like Thor
which when that movie did that I hated
it the second Thor like drops down into
the desert movie over for me like I love
the stuff in Asgard this was different
like the second she drops into London I
thought the movie came along getting
here and I was in yes Tatar and I like
this movie takes its time and you do not
feel bored I am Lajoie and it's what I
love running kind of like so over that
hat yeah and I told you I'm like it's
okay it's okay it does not be like a
fucking Transformers movie or Pirates of
the Caribbean or Man of Steel we would
not be at the end I started to feel a
little bored I will get to that but that
is saying something open to two and a
half hour movie and I was invested all
the way over the way through I felt like
this is a different universe this is a
DC movie no absolutely DC thrills right
in fear go oh whoops
coughing Marvel is ripping on market and
I'll guess what it's own thing and thank
God it showed that you can have a sense
of humor have characters that you give a
shit about it can be heavy it's heavy
Yami
give me a break fuckin cash the town in
the middle of this movie has the same
movie where you've got like literally
this kind of comedic scene where she's
trying on clothes they gasp a Belgian
village this movie's awesome no on top
of that you know you have the scene the
traditional scene of her being a hero
without giving away too much you kind of
see in a way with all in vain so what a
wonderful combination of both the glory
involves being a hero and then that
harsh reality of Vienna
coming together beautifully another
identification to everyone and the those
of you on the DC side have been praying
for something like this I feel your pain
I know you've been having to listen to
you're like fringe fanboy is anything
but all the critics who've had to put up
with them all the DC fans have had to
put up with them and being told that no
man of steel and BBS the greatest thing
ever that has to be done dark and gritty
in exactly this way vindication for us
all because this movie is amazing got it
right and still feels like a really good
DC movie you know and I'll tell you see
here's the other thing too you know I'll
talking about bringing it back to the
people and that's again this is very old
school ah you care about me no no no
it's not how that is gold don't know it
Marvel I care about all the characters
but here ever every character in a
Marvel movie is probably going to be a
hero introducing people so they can be
heroes
there are yeah people they are people
they are soldiers they are people none
and they come back and she's the only
real hero in this is a difference from
Marvel I think this needs to be said and
I love marble but there is a goofiness
to marble that that is their wheelhouse
like like we're just going to be goofy
and we're going to have fun in to a
certain degree someone's done a good job
but I don't quite take them is seriously
I'm just like okay everybody's goofy
everybody's crack and why is here
everybody's doing this even when
characters in this movie crack wise I
feel like I kind of connect with them on
a bit of a deeper level than I do in
some are woman you know as I was just
going to say it is X nighter had a great
quote and we don't like his Superman
movies but he has this wonderful quote
he said look you know all these are
super you know Batman is cool you know
and whatever Captain America is great
Superman is important and he knew that
even though he couldn't properly
represent that but I feel like okay no
no but here's the thing and every be
fair this Snyder let's put a lot of
blame on David Goyer one of the worst
screen alright he worked on the story
and this he
ya know I guess behind our heads good I
don't think Zack Snyder is solely to
blame I think it's a part of the problem
because he's being put in the wrong spot
mm-hmm but really when I look at what I
hate about those other two movies it's
the script the script is bullcrap but so
what I'm getting to is that with
Superman and Wonder Woman and not really
bad man so I need to be out there but a
lot of the DC he rode they were the role
models where Marvel was very much there
you you know your gap BL can you agree
with them in sense but there is
definitely be said about looking for his
role models I feel like we got so sucked
in to wanting to be the hero
understandably selling there done very
well but we did kind of lose you know
our Greek myths are gods you know that
we looked at in the idolize and we do
still see her a noise right but we can
still look back at it man I you know I
want to be this person will do what
they're doing but I understand their
flaws of LM people are impressive they
are God lines and if you're going into
this because I got some comments on my
public Facebook Lily
it's just you're terrible for hero's
journey all over you're like if plays it
says it's the same whole thing I'm like
no there is a key difference between
Marvel and DC Marvel is about humans
wanting to become superheroes and
balancing that act DC is about gods or
superheroes of people above humans
wanting to become human very very good
and that is what this movie does and you
can sit there and be like oh whoops the
heroes during again but we get that in
Marvel movies this is different because
it's taking it from a different point of
view and unlike Man of Steel it does it
right yeah I haven't seen probably cuz
bans its own thing probably Superman
yeah less mi so I think you know it see
property needs it right and same thing
with our super house by the animated
world like I'm gonna I'm distancing
myself from the animated world that is
don't think it's cool like a Superman is
the outsider as well coming to you know
our universe and real life and be
important and you know and everything
else what is it to be God but also be
human um and that is different and this
whole thing about over this movie
doesn't take risks we go through this
movie here
okay all right let's do this whalers yet
we start off in a movie set on a Greek
island of nothing but Amazon's so it's
something but women with a main
character is sculpted from clay brought
to life by Zeus it tells us this this is
not like we're gonna make it crazy and
real like we're gonna tell them it's
over like a fuckin dilaudid toy they
spend a lot of time on yeah we're sure
this whole thing and it's going to be
like Lord of the Rings the main lead I
love Chris Pine like he places
masculinity was like I'm cool I swear
but like he's an awesome character she
shakes his ass you know they make him
tell the truth Keith rides her around in
the middle of this movie like the
villains are trying to just gas people
the main you guys don't know the villain
yeah yeah one of the main villains is a
woman another main villain is like you
know it she goes on about like Aries is
supposed to be like a God of War they
guess like they have these funny scenes
where they talk about like what we've
decided that like it's not worth it to
basically like have sack so that men
aren't Nestle like you had goofy
conversations like that her trying on
clothes and then later they gasp a
fucking village yep
all this in the movie that doesn't take
risks yeah no risks it'll a say like oh
let's talk about yeah Batman fan plug
your ears she kills people
oh we don't buy that bullshit philosophy
off any what to kill people you can kill
people damn it fine if he doesn't what
we're fine with either one but he can't
bullshit and here's Wonder Woman going
around killing there's a big opening
Emmys hair window on film yeah yeah and
directed by a woman who has never done
an action film before I also like the
fact that like yeah no risks whatsoever
in this whatsoever I like I like the
fact too that originally they had a dry
girls a female director who did who
directed Game of Thrones and Brandi fat
and then either creative differences or
whether reason she left and they got
another female director who dragged the
Game of Thrones amazing and so it's like
and probably straying far somewhere
because obviously they have a
disagreement but I'm like wow that's
pretty lucky
yeah I mean
a good resume it's not like we've gotten
some seasoned male action directors I
would just pull John Woo out of our
Astor's eyelids so even job wounds not
really John Woo and I mean point being
things like there are a ton of riskier
because you could have played this
exactly you could have gone by the
Marvel playbook beginning to end and
take a no risk made it completely joking
the whole way through
not the invest not really kill anybody
because Marvel doesn't do that or you
could have done it what we've done the
past two times no personality compel is
completely out of order
there's only have the balls to tell a
story completely in order yeah you
realize that tell it completely all that
a little bit of a better story but yeah
then it does charge yeah 100 day oh and
I'll tell the backstory entirely in
Renaissance painting I mean I see that
happen all the time like yeah this movie
took risk left and right it did not play
it safe like a DC movie previous to this
it was not the same mold I say it would
be has tons of people you know it's a
life cut off in war and you know just
those people are dogs leave them those
are the soldiers - but Leroy big women
and Nick children are dead yes it's
funny good but I guess that it's not to
keep served its own mood it's been
moving it open with a little girl
smiling and like running around and my
girlfriend's the dollar movie Oprah
heavy starts to surf the character and
the plot and yeah journey and aside from
the air which we will get to it is not
very funny yesterday up in the end yeah
Anna Lee a bassist say it is not overly
talked about a lot of it you just see
and every time I think oh we're going to
do this stupid thing or this is where
it's going to get a little too corny or
cliched or at least to a bad point they
have such charm and such likability oh
you identify with them so long
one more decibel my mother in Christie
yeah let's play it safe instead of World
War two which is a very easy good versus
evil you got your Nazis that nobody
likes you know versus the Allies what's
going on World War one where everything
is a weird nebulous great
that's part of because she thinks it's
all one bad guy you know and they made
that work I depth I thought that was
going to be a great because I thought
how do you do this World War one's a
little more like you know like it's so
easy where World War two like this isn't
going to come off right I'll be damned
if they can figure out how to do it and
I pretty much bought it I bought all of
this acquired a thinker and I think when
again we're talking about making it
about the people the they get a group
together without happy to see I'm glad
it wasn't just her and pie that they get
a group together that's been happening
Erica but it's still fun oh yeah and
here's the thing they don't again in
Marvel like these characters notice I
hire through captain Marion car and I
like Captain America fine I don't know I
love Emperor yeah i all slam against a
movie no I don't worry as I care because
I remember rocky oh maybe I remember
them slightly because they appeared on
agent Carter and I remember Bucky
because he's in the next one yeah yeah
but apart from them like I don't
remember like I can remember all four
these guys easily yes like Diane's down
and I can remember lines they have head
that people want to go nuts about the
the Superman movie what lines to Perry
White have I can't even remember one hmm
or RGB halted or a sigh from bang like
nobody were men nobody even I would ever
to be wholesome uh you know and I'll say
to a guy remembers Halle hunters
character just because the peach tea
thing and that select ruther line really
lated well and be hunting and that scene
again in sort of the older Nolan driven
you know DC film they would sit down
talk about you met a what means that for
French and what it means to connect you
know what they're doing here they're
having humanity and they're connecting
they're not talking about it they're
doing it and she's connecting with these
people and I love it when that guy comes
you things gonna leave and he's just
like you know oh you got to put up with
you know I'm heading up a pair of
nothing now and she's like oh who's
gonna sing for us now and I would be
like oh that is like so nice
c'mon ugh and that your connection to
people being good you know it's not and
I walking about then I don't come enough
are on it they're actually doing good
and my good courage I don't want to
knock the Noland ones too much because
no one still knew that even if you're
going to have all of that talking he
still had characters
I remembered the Joker I remember to
know and you need everyone yeah yeah
because they did that much tiny
beforehand and you needed that talk I
don't remember the characters for
Manistee or Batman vs Superman except
for the fact that I thought Paul Kent
was fucking insane yeah um you know oh
and we'll have to save that for spoiler
corner but well you know the last thing
I'll say before we Bowie probably can
get into spoiler corner after this is
that I felt like no little Tim Burton's
Batman Nolan's Dark Knight and even
Batman Begins and this Wonder Woman all
came out at the right time when they
need to because there are these waves of
what we're seeing is superhero film many
of them finds differently with Marvel
are kind of getting a little tiring and
I feel like I'm on I feel like yes and
maybe Deadpool are kinda like the two
where I'm like Marvin Gaye always a
scratch on me for this but I am not
tapped out of Marvel but I'm like this
is hit a point where I'm just like I'm
seeing mostly a movie an again a moment
someone's enjoys movies but I'm
someone's Viking tend to be the really
like off kilter really side character
you know they would say there's like
five story no I like I like Guardian to
ant-man and kind of doing things more
than shit yeah but you know they always
think there's like five stories being
retold over and over and over and I feel
like we kind of get into telling this
story over and over and over and then
that gets on then we go telling this
story over and over and over that gets
old I feel like we had kind of like tin
you know Callie Richard Donner's
Superman Tim Burton's Batman crisper
Nolan's Dark Knight uh I will argue like
if maybe Avengers you know and now this
I feel like this is sort of the next
steps I need to take where this kind of
going back to you know making it about
the people but still the heroes grant
like you said God is humming human this
definite it's women you know
like an epic movie what Superman once
was what the donners Superman once was
and if if the Goyer snyder version could
have done it with just any sense of
competence like and that's more inquiry
but if they could have done i will i
okay different interpretation i'm okay
let's reinterpret this but it sucked
like it just it plain sucks so now we've
got this and i feel like this is this is
the film like DC WB DC so desperately
need it because i am we keep saying beta
DC we want videos WB like they're the
ones pulling a lot of the shots here and
then definitely you needed nemesis you
know bad and i'm i'm glad they finally
got it like i've been waiting and
waiting this is the second time I saw it
I thought was you were out yeah
it outside the first time I've seen a
frickin DC movie a second time since the
Dark Knight yeah I think uh this and
guardians of galaxy 2 are the only
movies I can think of where I'm this
year that might I could see that again I
could very easily see that again and
yeah when people say oh you just want a
Marvel film this is not a Marvel film
you you wanted you want the proof I know
when I wasn't getting gas no mom when I
was going in my first concern was is
this gonna be too much I Captain America
you know even though I know it's
different Wars but their countdown
similar wars you know people in trenches
and shooting and stuff like that and
good old-fashioned telephone hero coming
in and now what's divert all compares
out captain only only what I do plan to
together my kinda like Captain America
and then about maybe five minutes into
it I realize I'm a sailor like these bad
characters better than the ones who can
yeah no I think it says yes I love
Captain America it's actually one of my
favorite Marvel movies it's not a knock
against Captain America yeah Marvel is
cool and awesome you know I feel like DC
is epic and we haven't been saying that
anything this fella came the Hortons but
like I wanted to watch it yeah like like
the the previous DC movies were trying
so hard to be this is important this
means something
and David gory would tell you to his
dying day how much he means we're
deconstructing the whole superhero genre
and like but it didn't work this felt
like I'm like all this feels important
this feels si
really old-school Greek mythological
stuff and it worked it made me want to
see it a second time yeah okay so I
think we're going to go into spoiler
territory now we've you doing our video
for in my movie let's just talk about it
now just do it in one big video okay I'm
going to that my field problems honestly
they're all in the climax and they're
not major but they're distracting enough
so okay um they're building up like
Diana thinks this is you know general is
Airy seem the guy keeping it going we
all know it's not you know so he breaks
this powder bacon over our makes him
stronger but we know this is a good a
piece of very Java for I'm like this is
I'm like literally I was like Kenneth
ps4 controller xbox controller pop out
in front me so I can play yeah like it
really just feels like a video game so
this other do this British general was
that many wounds or voltage and
everybody was movement to be om Lupin
yeah from Harry Potter comes along to
herself she's Ares the whole time which
I was thankful because I thought they
were just gonna do an ink receipt once
within by the way there is no way
credits don't live we don't bother
waiting um go through the awesome
soundtrack been when the yeah actual end
credits are rolling um but uh so he
comes up says I am actually area so you
know ago war and but unlike before I
know I physically can't go I do so I go
and I inspire people I give them the
ideas but they still go and do this
stuff and they saw at the warrant and
I'm like okay I'm digging this her and
I'm liking this I'm saying but we still
need a big climax so he says you know
right now it'll just throw your or and
he starts floating around he's this old
guy come yeah like ian mckellen is
magneto you know just like in a robbery
orchards or yes but I'm like okay I'm
still with it okay and then he starts
getting this giant playmate starts
getting down our bestest no no first I'm
like okay cuz yeah I guess cool but then
I know what I know where to go get like
designs of the comic book version of
areas of guy Warren's usually this
helmet kinda like a black writer the
face is blocked out meteors let me go
first
a totally black hem and so and his armor
comes together any you know with his
metal llama I figure if he call you get
those low looking someone inside what he
said the man yeah well what's this size
that can be totally dark with just some
glowing eyes so it's gonna be like a
scallop and let's again be it's just
this fucking old face movement it's just
my lambs I'm like there's something
alluring about like this dude like it
I'm just gonna fade he's kind of dorky
looking like this boy and that's his
best is character like there's a mess
the whole movie was hell that's prime
minister da yo you know else giant opium
just don't go to dorky-looking like god
help me if i were an actor and
somebody's like we're gonna put you into
all this cool armor and I'm like cool
you got to digitize my face or like blow
fire now it's gonna be your normal face
week though you oh I'm like maybe look
cool like I know what I think I slay I
see what I look like a Batman mask I
know I will not look go ahead you gotta
figure out ya know I'm with you they
should have it should have been blacked
out or something and it's this this is
where it gets a little too much into the
talking or he's like ha ha ha no you see
here if this is where I kind of sound
like a Marvel movie because the villains
over explained and the funny thing ends
like a messiah or where he was Sean on
the one hand okay so there's this weird
there's a weird thing going on here
because on the one hand the this feels
so much like the Snyder verse all of a
sudden the snipers comes I can we gotta
punch each other for like a zillion
times and but honestly I thought this
handled it better I was more interested
better but maybe because the hood will
the rest of the movie built yeah I
didn't love it but I'm just like okay
I'm willing to put up with this because
this sequence is still shorter than
anything in transformers and Batman vs
Superman and I like everything else
built around the sequence yeah but
you're completely right for as much as
this felt like a Schneider II kind of
like climax the dialogue is pure marble
yeah and it's the only time I'm like
this feels like a Marvel movie and like
if there was ever a point where I'm just
like
not want a Marvel movie like this I'll
give that to DC when they are just
fighting they just fight all the time
I'm gonna sit down Rhea talk about this
going to be very dry sometime very
boring it out like that money when they
fight they just fight and here it's like
hard oh you died oh yeah the only the
only line that I kind of like just
because it was a callback the beginning
was very um deserved order but it's so
like it wasn't great but I'm like legit
point Lana um but and you feel her
struggle you feel like yeah this is a
tough time like a great mega it's like
you know for me I like gal gadot in this
movie a lot I've been waiting for godot
um dad ever did use that joke um but I
just know I forget some she's very
interesting I there's almost a
Schwarzenegger like quality of the
accents very thick and you can see her
trying to work through that and so I
don't hold that against her but some of
the line reads are very for me when
Steve when they do that callback thing
and Steve's is like I gotta go like I
can save the day or whatever but you can
save the world as you know like but some
of the line reads you've got there's
like hardware's is like not be no none
opportunities dude they don't know
sitting there that's after annex I
thought they're hitting it was after an
explosion and she can't hear she may be
your God so she's what I thought it was
kind of bad there's there the first time
yeah so when you can't hear with an
author there's other reads where I'm
just like yeah I mean this wasn't
perfect but I think she's doing her best
like and I would say the same thing
about Schwarzenegger who I love watching
it's just like sometimes the accent it's
hard to but she makes up for it a
hundred percent in her ability to remote
like the way she emotes through this
whole movie is amazing but I don't know
if it was a directing thing if nobody
checked her colder back because for all
of the moding she does and she captures
this kind of like childlike innocence of
like just looking at the world around
her and just not getting it like we're
all messed up um you know there are some
moments like after Steve blows himself
up
that whole person yeah I'm just like
alright let's tone it down a bit there's
a little much yeah first man you've ever
met the first person you've ever really
fallen in love with and suddenly he's
gone we don't even know if she heard
what he would say I like them I like the
know like he was everywhere
Wow but hello what you're fuckin all got
it or not yeah afterwards like the
camera just is weird vigorous like
panning left and right it's in super
slo-mo and it's almost like she's
looking for where the camera is and it's
just I didn't quite work free but again
these are not like film killers is if I
can and it's easy I'm glad melodramatic
like but it's like a bigger nitpick no
I'm glad are you really reaching for
shit here for all these movies trying to
do like the god thing I'm so goddamn
sick of movies having the you know Jesus
symbolism you know is the first time
like this and I mean they all do it and
with this one it's like the sacrifice is
not from her a job here I'm going in and
if anything will kind of shock me at
they did in this movie is after night
happened know she gets under our I
thought it sounds going to be like the
good in humanity he sacrificed himself
you know that means that there's good
but he's do you like haha yours even he
couldn't say even he'll like what I'm
not following this philosophy at all I
totally don't follow yes the female that
gets killed to give the me a chicken the
bridge yeah he ate the chicken the
bridge in this one oh I thought there's
water but I didn't and here's the thing
like we joke about that but it didn't
feel like that I didn't feel like oh
this is arbitrary like their connection
felt real his sacrifice felt real I love
this final seeing pine was acting his
ass oh my god um I love to read it
i I just bought the whole thing hook
line and sinker he's like I have to do
this and from a story perspective it's
like well it's not like he's going to
live forever and I figured they just
didn't want to do the thing they don't
have to America where they just age in
continue yeah I saw one that I saw the
picture is suddenly hit me about halfway
through I'm like all these people have
to die yeah always people were dead
like that I only kind of a shame um and
there's a wit I will say this there is
something that I didn't think about much
until after the fact which is at first I
didn't like showing the picture at the
beginning and then at the end because it
reminded me that they have a vs.
Superman exists my crappy movie like but
what I look at it made me realize that
is much I'm so in her moving face and
like oh the innocent and childlike I
didn't get any of that
hmm out of the beginning and the ending
she was a completely acting like a
completely different person in the book
ends of this film and I'm like oh holy
shit like that that's acting like III
didn't get that sense of naivety is the
sense of someone who's seen a lot of
shit now and might be kind of jaded and
is reconnecting like and I'm like yeah
one thing even like at the end I'm kind
of thinking like cuz they show where
she's in Europe right there yeah in
Paris and I just remember it's like you
know and she because I'm thinking that
too because all they have is this
picture of her and nobody else has ever
seen anything it's like even Batman has
like newspaper clipping and what if this
was and stuff like that and this one all
we have is this picture and somehow
nobody recalls like if they all kind of
die the more I think about it I don't
nobody recalls sisters woman in this war
and then she just kind of disappears and
well perfect yeah it's like a room or
two hello
where were you there oh no I don't know
but that at the very end is like you did
it but I will be there I will be the
fighter I will be and she's jumping
towards Paris and there is the part of
me that I am kind of like know what
about a little cooler bells like New
York or is that you live in your set
like I know it's like we go overboard
with like with a minor man the American
divorcee much like that but like she was
wearing a shirt World War was whatever
but but like that lion was hacking on a
hundred miles from Paris I do I feel
like she's like the American superhero
though you know it's like I don't
necessarily need vitamin in front of the
American flag all the time I'm like in
telling fucking Fox News is adjourned
murica no but it's not American if Sean
Hannity ain't like sprinkling his own
let you see star del X Jim okay no
here's the thing if she's like no the
time has come for me to
not a retirement now some bullshit that
where I continue another movie is
calling me and then wiping out okay like
I will continue to fight it's like we're
are you all ve heard what were you doing
out it yet but yes why was coming up
with all the other chances because I
think about what God was around what is
the wait for dickless not to come and
you know and destroy everything my doing
that ain't no problem he's not a Greek
god by me as well I I got I got the
impression that he's an alien he's like
a Greek guy guy I got the impression
that after going through the whole world
war one shit she's like I ain't gotta
work some shit out and be I don't want
that to work up shit out I think be it's
just I stopped looking it I don't know
whether you're sick I don't know but
you're gonna be the bug eyes no I think
what is there joy such a did I think
he's still working out whether she wants
to truly help humanity I think she's
been sitting on the sidelines going like
well I killed Ares know what am i used a
change that I just I don't fuck I'm not
saying there's a I feel I don't follow
if you like seeing the picture she read
because the person in her life who made
her reconnect with the sort of humanity
that she was seeking basically this
whole time like becoming more human and
it's all about love and stuff was Chris
Pine character is Steve Trevor so she
goes to the war Trevor is dead my guess
is she's grieving she then watches his
humanity gets sucked again into another
war she's like Ares is dead she's like
these people were just fucking like this
like and maybe there is nothing I could
do maybe she becomes Jada's you sits
there lives in hiding
why don't you know what until she sees
the original picture maybe then maybe
your neighbors and maybe they'll under
inspire now if you're like why I'm to
New York or America
why the fuck would she be when every
other fucking superhero is there she
wants to lay low goodbye no no whatever
I'm in spin cocks no don't drop what do
you mean in Suicide Squad Batman's not
around the flash isn't around Superman
no
well that's why they gotta get when I
dress
yeah I dress so many stupid opinion
pieces about this like there's the Fox
News we will turn Merkin a marker your
just G starts and strives there's
another one like if like it's on CNN and
I'm not sharing any of these because I
don't even people are even the garbage
but the other ones is like the feminist
thought home and we were wearing for a
long as there is all where they know
they excited like something like is a
character of Wonder Woman is some sort
of like oh we know what is like Women's
Studies feminism something else and all
be really good there's plenty close eye
on make sure they're on board
Google her and there and like of course
like this is I think a friend of mine
put it as like yeah this is what I want
to hear like a feminist argument from
some white guy who's twenty years older
than me lecturing me about feminist
icons but like no some men your true way
who would prefer that slaughter women
shared more screentime like go see the
figures or Erin Brockovich or other ya
know II Listed this and I think I'm
going these are all Oscar Bay movies and
guess what the same shit happens to men
you think men like you go to any summer
movie it's all a bunch of like guys with
great chest like blowing up shit with
machine guns like this is just the
summer movie thing and now that we
finally have a woman leading this it's
like it's not from the moon enough for
me my wife just straight up is like wow
what a fucking a doll don't know there
was I know I have not met one one
there's one woman I've met who is like a
spouse of a brad like who didn't like it
oh and every woman I've met who's seen
this and it's a bunch look this movie
and I'm like well jokester enough from
Anniston oh no I saw something but any
pieces on both sides of this are
horseshit okay guys I saw something
where it's like I forget you can look it
up I forget what it is but there was
some sort of thing where it's like the
character Wonder Woman was being is that
you know like kind of playful because
she's not real person but something
it's like you know speaker for women or
something women college in the United
Nations thing I think so that sounds
right and are not a ton of feminists
were like you know what we can't allow
her look at what she's wearing that just
doesn't she's not a true hero she's just
I see any is up its Linda Carter
literally said um crow the fuck oh my
god oh my
Linda Carter by the way who's one of my
heroes I love Windsor Carter first crush
okay also a hero yeah that's the first
Wonder Woman ever I didn't even know
about the common oh no no no no no no no
no I feel like and that's all the way I
almost cut it stupid if probably goes
without saying okay here's the
assumption and the assumption here and I
think it's bullshit which is ladies you
can enjoy the same thing the boys like
because you're supposed to be better
than them oh yeah they can be as awful
as we are purple I don't kind of like
saying that enjoy the fact that you've
got like a female superhero that's like
and that's kind of like saying Jax from
gal guardians of the galaxy can't be in
like a war hero Museum where sci-fi
museum so because he has his shirt off
it's like shuttle I might well my
supposed to sit here and just be upset
all day because I'm like I go and see
action movies like where is the doughy
fat ass representation of great blowing
up shit like shirtless anomalous now
like a little prettier oh yeah I like
this is just the way Society has
standards of you know if you're like all
those stairs is the birria wrong fine
but don't sit there and say like well
women can have the same amount of fun
with their super heroines that we do
because we look from you know you know
bullshit article okay here's what I like
if Brad goes without saying that you
know we've done all the DC movies we've
done them those quick reviews we're
going to do this one too you know just
it goes without saying cuz we've done
all the Arditi movies again I think
there's a lot to talk about with I would
not do a DC movie there's nothing
or any moving it with nothing to talk
about but um I feel like regardless of
whatever political anything I feel like
this is just a good movie and there are
times where they're like yeah you know
like in World War one well it's a
different time we couldn't do this and
then we're expect to do that
so and they do talk about them they do
have the outsider aspects and they have
talks about how bad War II because but
if I'd element to that time and whether
or not you want to read into that now
they're you know doesn't matter is done
well and it's a good movie and to me
that's one of the things I like about is
that I can watch this movie and not give
a shit politically about anything I can
hold as : join blur Breitbart Fox News
MSNBC yeah a lot of wars bullshit it's
fucking Wonder Woman yeah it's just a
good movie fighting for your rights in
your sanitized what I it's just like
stop taking it so seriously I feel like
I can talk about this there were so many
girls at our boys like I saw a bunch of
families I both the girls and boys alike
do we do awesome and like according to
the servant no I shit you not this
article is just like you need to educate
your children tone that women are not
all bodacious babes who can kick ass in
are there to serve the men and I'm like
wow you know every time I see soon if
it's not that if you need to tell them
better than Wonder Woman is just pure
blooded American and she's there to kick
some like oh no terrorists and they let
me go oh good remind myself not all men
look like that I fucked up right I look
like fucking sore yeah or Superman
different people Captain Bob does I mean
is don't get me wrong if you see me as
you know as good-looking a Superman or
thorium though I will not I got you
Plaza I don't think you do I guess in
quickly my my only gripes about the
movie I'm with you on the climax I'm
like yeah a little cheesy um I think the
only other thing and again this always
the issue I have here this is nothing to
do with violence or killing because my
past M is to be like whom I won't watch
something let's throw an either evil it
to a Robocop because they're amazing
your um yeah the originals you Poe
remember there's a rebound
who remembers that so my memories is no
you do like you want don't make ending
on my compared to facing that way like
but when your whole thing is like your
whole moral compass the whole basis of
the movie is like I've believed in peace
and love and and and like helping others
and you just like slaughter like thirty
forty German soldiers like August and
there's like this kinda reminds me of
Iron Man which is like we should not be
making weapons I'm going to solve the
world's problems for violence yeah I
don't know again yeah and the thing is
it's not it does not kill the movie for
me in any way because I realized this
was like a comic trope but I just always
laughed for him is like like at the very
end when uh Ares drags Maru out and he's
like birds on shoes and were there hope
some wrap-up doctor poison thank you the
much cooler Nettie I never heard this
bill doctor when I heard that name of
what'll be out of my love and I note I
loved her and Dusseldorf or new door for
whatever signs of her very phantom they
asked the two the two of them together
and that see where he tosses the gas in
and she's like put the mask I want these
two days I wanted more about happy but I
want you to have a spin-off movie but um
someone he's like she's not where the
diner destroy her and become like me in
behind she's like no I believe in love
and like really tell it like the forty
German soldiers you totally killed you
know
he's killed a lot more you know I was
thinking the same thing I just thought
of this right now possibly mmm right but
maybe the idea I get kind of like in two
towers maybe idea is that it's not
necessarily you know Oh love conquers
all is that love is worth fighting for
that's worth killing for and defending
it I feel I could find fault in that to
the only logical argument is a bit
you're in the middle of a battle and
therefore she's not really thinking like
that so he's like who's gonna stop us
like Cooper bulleted but I'm sure now
yeah uh it is another large because
there would have been a way to fix this
and I would have killed it the movie
into this and it would have been like a
Marvel trade but
it would have been interesting if
because everybody else wants the
armistice and I don't buy that this is
all Aries doing I think people miss the
point on that is everybody wants the
armistice except for Ludendorff I
thought it would have been great if
Ludendorff has this cadre of soldiers
they're like yeah we're with you war war
war war and they made it clear that
these are Ludendorff SMED that this is
not just the German army proper if they
had done that I know okay these guys
want to continue the war when the rest
of the Germans want to give it up and
does that they never really made that
distinction so I was like well these
guys are just following orders and
you're fine killing them but the woman
who really wants to poison everybody
you're like no no like Ellie remember
what happened sir actually the more I
said given if encounters away I think
she throws the tank you know and I long
and again doesn't kill the movie I'm
like these are just knit pigs but it
always makes me laugh wife is like and
we're on the docket peace and love like
you just like Toby took out thirty guys
you know there's something and this was
this is about the closest to the Jesus
symbolism you can get even and I think
it's a stretch if I like the way this
was done and you were saying some people
already miss miss reading it I thought
was really interesting so after she
kills Aires
you know she comes down like this but
I'm like have you ever fallen down from
a high your arms do go out so it's like
and she doesn't sacrifice anything so I
don't really read it as symbolism but
she comes down every mars-like Zod's
minions when they do a lot of week when
they fly they get down like that it's a
job it's a god-like pose but it's really
what it is the Sun is coming up and all
the soldiers both the American and then
the German they're all even though the
Ares and everything has been destroyed
there Kelly when they're kind of happy
they're alive and they're hugging each
other and stuff and it's kind of just
people and I thought and they did say it
dancing they just let people be people
and they hug each other I'm not even
fighting but just okay and you know I
might Niko I have never been to one I
have never been in a war chances are if
you're watching you haven't either
if you're watching me though I said some
people someone has some people yeah no
bad people yes
at watch s thank you thank you for your
service and everything but I get the
feeling that depending on the situation
indefinitely you hear about stories with
is at least world war two and stuff like
that or even the Civil War that the word
times where people it's like look there
are times where if it's possible you can
look for the human you just want to be
human from it you are trained to be a
machine but when you're allowed to be
human and you know it's safe you know
you can be human you will take that
opportunity to be human and I feel like
it's mostly a German camp and there's
those four guys with form areas over
there who are don't have any weapons
they're just hung you tear do they are
all just happy to be alive after all
then after everything in that climate
some kind of like very I get that I feel
that I in whatever side I was on I would
be happy just to be alive there is a bad
there's been a huge miss reading from
some people because they'll they'll like
let me know it's just like I saw this
movie and they it was going on the right
track in a completely ruined it because
it turns out at the end Ares is
responsible for everything I'm like you
didn't watch movie right then made it
very clear and airy says straight up
multiple times he's like I didn't do
shit he's like gave them idea they used
those ideas for their own mall Ares did
was imagine two people showing up to a
knife fight with knives all Ares and
they're going to stab each other all
areas did was said here use these guns
instead that is yeah have you ever
thought the idea of this gun you know if
you didn't even give them the gun he
said have you ever thought of this and I
love that I love that he's being
innovative he just and he isn't even the
inspiration for killing he says he's
like I didn't inspire them to kill they
were going to do this anyway I'm glad
Afghan adjust love yesterday and we're
he's having your cake and eating it too
it guys the right way build a million to
do it better
mmm he's like and if you get rid of me
like pretty much that's what he was
saying you get rid of me doesn't matter
they're still going to do it that was
his whole point to Diana yeah so many
people miss that completely and you know
what if you fell asleep but I'm just
like it was not Ares fault
when you were saying that people were
reading in that after
Aries was dead oh it sounds like they're
really everybody valley and no not what
I got I got that they were I got humid
yeah I guess they were now tree yeah
human again okay so during the great uh
the Christmas truce where everybody got
together and sang sila I was like was
that because they were released by Airy
spells like no they all just cracked and
they're bad Buffy just can't do this for
one night like fuck this a mean - what a
wonderful way of showing that again not
having to over n late as they just show
it but again if people are miss reading
that maybe that's why do you feel we
have to spell everything out and white
feed it spell it out yeah how you missed
it like because it was so spun oh no no
I see I mean see handle a usual DC movie
whatever going so yeah look at them
they're hugging each other even though
we are enemies oh no cut that basically
show it sounds like it sounds like a
gory script yeah no just trust that
people will get it and it sounds like
the majority did but about some dins and
you know if that's your interpretation
fair enough my interpretation everything
that i will be aziz to support its
various identities of a one it's a giant
explosion - god is falling from the sky
who can probably just blast you with
their laser cops just descends and looks
around three these guys all get up for
the only Allied soldiers are there were
these four guys they're surrounded
anyway and though everything is blown up
I think the Germans and the everybody
was just like fuckin no like I just I'm
just glad to be alive like they don't
matter that after seeing all of that I
would just be happy to be alive I think
people are mistreating the fact that the
war ended that was cos Ares he said no
they were gonna sign a fucking armistice
if he came with the beginning of the
copy yeah
you know they come up with this on his
own Ares was just trying to prolong it
by saying like well I can inspire them
to better weapons and maybe convince
some of a morass Holy Ones to you know
but it's not that killing Ares just
brought about like world peace it was
some people were there right and that
was her point which is like they're
capable the more of what you're saying
you're enabling them but there is some
that won't work
use the drink and the world's rate the
coolie that's the last thing I'll say
because I feel like we've probably
talked as much as we can about this uh
the shit wasn't going to say oh yeah one
thing I like that I do not see in many
BC films uh my real it just films in
general are very important uh there's
mystery aspect and you know there's two
major ones uh one is what diana is uh
you know she sculpted from clay she's an
amazon but like she's something out we
don't want to know what you look at also
touring it goes into his hand
God killers I would bullshit oh yeah and
as far as I know a year ago yes not
knowing a ton about the backstory by
here she has a couple of backstories and
if I'm right it sounds like they kind of
combined them all very cleverly and they
utilize this mystery aspect and the
other thing is whether or not Ares is
actually a part is because they're
making it look like there really is no
Ares in any of this war and then they
can reveal a little fairy there was
someone you didn't necessarily suspect
and everything and with me I thought it
was I knew the British prime minister he
was up to something I didn't know he was
Ares so that she wasn't going I and you
don't see that in the DCU movie our dad
apparently figured it out right away
like I knew practically from the
beginning like that it is that he that
Lupin was Ares I'm like I didn't cuz I
wasn't looking for I know as soon as he
gave them the money to go on the mission
or whatever I'm like okay he's not a
good guy he's up why would they give him
such this role you know if he actually
was not a good guy so I knew something
was up I was one happy I didn't I didn't
know where they were going if they were
going to go the ride and I think he sees
Diana and she's looking for it yeah and
he's a good deceiver and I really enjoy
that me like where I figured it out it
was just the second moon Dorf gets
stabbed I'm like that can't be yeah I
can't because I knew looking at him like
but Ludendorff is dead
so like within that 10 seconds after he
gets stabbed and like oh it's move on
he's or Lupin he's basically Ares like
so I figured it out there but
again I wasn't like sometimes with twist
was like you're not really looking for
anything you're just taking a movie at
face value because I was kind of in
everything no area yeah he's not
involved it wasn't honestly thinking it
was going to be that twisty so look
whatever we'll just see what happens but
yeah when an F and I'm like it's him but
yeah good uh you know um but at the very
end I will be the only other thing I'll
say is like for those who just want to
believe that like oh but every so if
everything goes the war into that word
really then why was there world war two
in every other war we got a couple other
things going on V box human history
proved your theory wrong yeah um so yeah
you know and what really gives me hope
about this movie too is that you know
the good things from Batman V Superman
or Wonder Woman and for the most part
Batman mm-hmm that the bad movie will be
good they're like they'll really really
get that in retrospect I wish Batman V
Superman was just called Batman and
Wonder Woman and they cut Superman out
and nothing of value would have been won
well honestly they were the best part of
the movie
honestly man even right even get shut
out League movie is kind of like you
know get Superman is not in I'm like I'm
kind of I don't you he wanted to the
trailers you're not going to be in this
movie I'm like often cannot and you
thought a bad character inches ago no
that's like I like your man is a
character yet and yeah and then
execution of it no yeah so is that I
don't need super in as a carrot and the
best comics when I don't like this
execution the best up is when Batman
Wonder Woman were together I mean any
times they're talking like ooh this is
like a cool kick-ass spy movie but with
superhero so it's even cooler
uh yeah I'm hoping that means the Batman
movie will be good and then you know
figure across the Justice League movie
is a gorgeously shot them the actions
great eyes is the YSL she's like fucking
spyglass to work she thought she had
Simon Belmont on a crystal meth binge in
yeah I use that right Han sylvania shit
going on there yeah oh and just like my
favorite kind of scene in the movie just
were what's when we're sailing and
they're just talking and it's like both
revealing bits about their character
will not being like we're having super
important conversation ever thought
about humanity matrix matrix matrix talk
matrix cause major this I know it's just
there's just a pita feel example in
probably for people just being deep like
being hero I got to know who these
people were
I got to know where she's coming from
where he's coming from I saw her going
from a God to trying to understand a
human like it just I'm so perfect
yeah it was it's a good good movie I
will if if some of these kind of cliches
bother you kind of the fish out of water
I still like you better than Thor yeah
no no so do I uh you know and kind of
like what is humanity worth fighting for
it is we're fighting for is that stuff
really really bothers you even if it's
done well you know is this will proud
ice machine bridges so you're hurting an
iPad well she and Chris Pine had cameras
yeah if it a job well money's in the
latest pirates movie has zero chemistry
yeah and freaking the war and I remember
what her characters and Natalie Harmon
had zero chemistry not going to be the
third book movie I'm so excited
Thor movie maybe the first one I'm like
really psyched yeah so um yeah we dug it
we talked endlessly about it there's
more talking to be done about how do you
put in a very different way I'm sure and
yeah I just Haley until the next
hopefully good for you good be seen man
I hope that mrs. sharp I hope you are
like oh man after Wonder Woman they got
so good they got so good so let's let
those myself this is the beginning so uh
you're screwed that's about it and
seven